hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna talk
about some news that's been going around
about the final two seasons of Game of
Thrones I left this out of my last
spoilers video because it's not really
related to what's gonna happen in the
story so this is spoiler free but there
has been some discussion about how much
actual time is left in the series so I
was gonna go over what we know
last April Dan and Dave mentioned that
they thought there was about 13 episodes
left of the series Game of Thrones David
Benioff one of the showrunners had
mentioned that he thought they were down
to the final 13 episodes and that they
were heading into the final lap at that
time he also added that the decision to
wind things down was not just about
trying to not overstay their welcome but
that they were trying to tell a cohesive
story with a beginning middle and end
they've known the end for quite some
time
and they're hurtling towards it Daenerys
is finally heading to Westeros Jon Snow
is king in the north
and Cersei is sitting on the Iron Throne
the knight King is up there waiting for
all of them the pieces are on the board
now and we're heading towards the
endgame so from that interview we got
the idea that there was probably going
to be seven episodes in season seven
which meant that season eight would be
the finale with only six episodes in the
past few weeks though we've had a couple
other interviews that make this sound
like it might not be the case liam
Cunningham who plays Davos did an
interview at the Golden Globes where he
sort of backed up the story of seven
episodes in season seven and six
episodes in season eight he mentioned
that they're still filming season seven
now and they will be until the end of
February and that they would come back
in September to film the final six
episodes in season eight Ian Glen who
plays Jorah Mormont did an interview
with Radio Times where he pretty much
said the same thing but there's a little
bit of difference in what he said he's
quoted as saying they are taking the
length of time it takes to shoot ten
episodes to shoot just seven this year
and six next year there are fifteen more
hours left in throne
as we understand it but that may change
but that's as far as we know so he says
they'll be seven and six but they're
taking more time to film those episodes
and there is a possibility that the
number of episodes might change based on
what they're shooting he also mentioned
15 hours which we know is longer than
the 13 that Dan and Dave kind of alluded
to back in April so what does it mean I
mean it could mean that there are going
to be like an extended season premiere
and an extended season finale Westworld
did a 90-minute season finale that shows
that that's definitely possible and it
actually didn't seem stretched out at
all it was actually pretty perfect so
they could be going that route or he
kind of just made a mistake but I kind
of doubt that I mean if they're spending
so much time shooting then that would be
a good indication that the at least that
the episodes might be a little bit
extended when they need to be probably
the most interesting story about this
came out when Casey boys told
Entertainment Weekly why HBO hadn't
signed up for season eight of Game of
Thrones yet he mentioned that Dan and
Dave were still figuring out the shape
of the season and what they want to do
for Season eight that is do you know
season sevens already locked in he says
that he'll take as many as they want to
do if you give if they give me eight
I'll want ten but it's really up to them
they'll let me know so he basically said
that it's not certain how many episodes
season eight will be in another
interview he gave to TV Line he said
that he hopes that the show runners will
opt for more than six episodes for
season eight he told TV Line that
they're still figuring it out because I
think they're trying to get a shape of
the season they always do what they
think will yield the best version of the
show it's all about how many they're
comfortable with but I'll always take
more based on all the different articles
I read I think that it's likely we won't
know anything about the full episode
count for Season eight until after
season seven is in the can but what do
you guys think do you think that longer
episodes would be good or would you
prefer to have
extra weeks to wait in between to think
about what's going on I'm pretty torn
overall because I enjoy longer episodes
but one of the things that I've always
loved about Game of Thrones is that week
in between of the anticipation and
wondering what's gonna happen and
talking to all your friends about you
know what happened in the last episode
so a part of me would like to see it
stretched out as long as possible
without you know adding too much filler
going away from their original idea
Watchers on the wall pointed out that
you know pretty much all of us want it
to last forever and you know our quick
answers gonna be more we want to just
see more all together but they made the
point that with no books to go off of
you know in the Song of Ice and Fire
series you know they basically just have
ideas about what George is gonna do
maybe you know maybe a shorter end in
the TV show is actually the best
possible outcome and you know I think
there's some sense in that but I also
you know really just don't want the show
to end because it's been such a big
thing for over these last years but let
me know what you guys think I would tend
to think that 70 minute episodes would
be fantastic because we'll get to watch
a little bit more in each individual
episodes but at the same time I don't
want only a 6 episode season it just
seems like it'll fly by so you know I
just want you know I want to put it out
there and see what you guys think keep
you up to date with the news KC boys
also gave us some prequel news he said
that you know a spin-off would be less
likely than a prequel because they could
use so much of the material that's
already out there he said a prequel
feels like it has a lot less pressure
than a spinoff he basically said author
George RR Martin's history of Westeros
gives you areas in which you could tell
a writer go ahead and check this out
write it out flush it out and then we'll
see what we get whenever the writer
comes back he added though that he
didn't feel any pressure that we have to
have something I made a video about this
probably a month and a half two months
ago when they mentioned that they were
in talks about the prequel and I laid
out all the best options I thought they
had to start with and then we had a
pretty good at do you know discussion in
the calm
on what people would actually like to
see in that so if you haven't seen that
video you should check it out but as I
said then I think it's pretty much a
done deal they'll find something that's
worth doing that they think will you
know have the same quality and you know
that they don't have to rush and throw
together I mean the the contents already
out there the stories are there they
just have to get the right people behind
them all right that's it for today
please like the video if you enjoyed it
make sure you chime in in the comments
and tell me what you think do you want
to see long episodes do you want to see
more episodes do you want to see a
prequel make sure you subscribe because
on my book giveaway is still going on
all you have to do is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this one or any
of the other videos where I mention this
giveaway and when I hit 28,000
subscribers I'll pick one of those
comments to send a copy of the game of
Thrones 20th anniversary edition to that
commenter thanks for watching I'll talk
to you soon